so first of all we all lead really busy
lives we have to go to work we see our
friends we go outside all the time but
actually during the pandemic now more
than ever we stay at home a large part
of our day we have to work at home we
have to study at home we see friends
through skype at home so our home
environment is becoming more and more
our
main environment
therefore
our home is becoming super important in
our lives and we kind of want to create
a space that can inspire us that can
reduce stress and help us reach our
goals
so in this episode i want to talk a
little bit about how our environment can
help reduce stress or can cause stress
and which environmental factors you have
to think about when you want to redesign
your home such that you can create an
optimal
man case to reach your study or perhaps
your working goals
so grab yourself a coffee
and let's have coffee time
so when we think of our environment we
may consider only the things that we can
see but there are actually two other
senses that are really important and
that's what we can hear and what we can
smell so i will go over all three of
these senses
and talk a little bit about how we can
optimize them to increase this perfect
zen-like atmosphere
so let's first dive a little bit into
stress
so our stress response is actually
regulated by the hypothalamic pituitary
adrenal axis or hpa for short
and this includes our hypothalamus
our pituitary gland which is this
pre-like gland under our thalamus and
lastly our adrenal gland
and when we are in a stressful situation
this access then ensures that we go from
a sustenance state of relaxing and
digestion towards a stressful state or a
stress response which is an increased
heart rate or increased blood pressure
and if this stressful state is
maintained for a long time this can
actually lead to heart failure or stroke
or other
adverse bodily
issues as well as mental issues and
usually this stress respond is triggered
by external factors such as a bear
approaching but sometimes they can also
be triggered by involuntary
internal or external
factors such as for example when you
enter a really messy room and you think
about oh [ __ ] i have to clean this
and i don't have the time to do this
when am i gonna do this then our stress
response is also triggered our blood
level rises and if this continues for a
long time then this leads to adverse
health effects so let's first talk a
little bit about our visual environment
and how this can be used to increase or
decrease our stress levels
so most of us are nowadays staring at
our screen all day but our visual field
is actually a little bit larger and this
is to ensure that we're always alert for
certain attacks from bears for example
that could enter our environment at any
time
but it is also shown that having
visual clutter around you can be
monitored even if you're not looking at
it
so visual clutter is everything in your
visual environment
and this can increase your stress
response so doing a merry condo here and
there is maybe not a bad idea so this is
then one of the factors that can
increase our stress response but there
are also certain things that can
decrease our stress response and one of
these things has been shown to be nature
or having plans around us for example
this researcher roger ulrich
showed that patients that were in their
hospital room that overlooked a growth
of trees actually had a better recovery
trajectory than the patients that
overlooked a brick wall
so this shows that nature can really
reduce our stress response and increase
our recovery
and another thing why
researchers think that nature is so good
is this so-called attention restoration
theory
so nature allows us to have this soft
focus or soft fascination as they call
it
and this is that nature grabs our
fascination without us having to
consciously put effort for it
and because this is kind of an
unconscious process of fascination our
attention resources can then
increase again for when we have to put
hard attention on something so there are
then two factors that nature can help us
with and one of them is our stress
response to decrease this and the other
is attention restoration which can go up
with nature so having a lot of plants
around you and this urban green jungle
is maybe not only super aesthetic but
also super good for your mental
well-being as well so another important
factor is actually light in our visual
environment so light is one of the most
important things that controls our
circadian rhythm and our circadian
rhythm
is the rhythm that tells us when we have
to go to bed when we are sleepy and when
it's time to wake up and our circadian
rhythm is
reset by the amount of sunlight we
receive during the day so it's really
important to get enough sunlight during
the day even if you're at home
most of the day and therefore i would
recommend for example to put your
working desk next to a window or
somewhere where there's enough light
or to go outside if that's still
possible
and another thing to consider is to keep
light out during the night so not to
have this blue light from your screen
for example or even the light from the
moon can disturb our sleeping rhythms so
think about this when you're creating
your nighttime environment as well
so then for the visual environment we
have two things to consider one is to
have nature around us at all times and
the other is to have a good light source
during the day the second environmental
factor that i want to talk about is the
things we can hear
so it has been shown by research that
bad noise such as construction noise or
your neighbor screaming all day can
increase our stress response even if
it's subconscious
so investing in a pair of really good
noise cancelling headphones in my
opinion is really important if you live
in the city such as i do or if you don't
have money for that just getting a pair
of really good earplugs could also do
the job and for a positive reduction of
stress
and increase of relaxation we can think
of music therapy so there has been a lot
of research into music therapy but
it is really individualized what people
like in their music so for example for
some people rock music
may be really relaxing whereas other
people like to listen to more classical
music
but in general it has been shown that if
people listen to the music they prefer
their psychological as well as
physiological
response to stress goes down
so it is a good idea to just invest in a
nice speaker and put on your favorite
music if you want to have a little
relaxing
moment during the day
and lastly i want to talk about a little
bit of forgotten sense and that is smell
so the olfactory system is the system
that records what we smell in our
environment
and bad smells such as urine or
something rotten has been shown to
increase our stress response
so just cleaning your space is already
pretty important but there's also a lot
of
research into
smells that could help us reduce our
stress response but the thing is with
smell it's one of the senses that's
extremely correlated to emotional memory
so what people find smelling
nicely is really individualized to their
memory and their experience
so for example if you really like the
smell of sunflowers
because it reminds you of this one trip
you took to france where you were
cycling through the sunflower fields
for another person this may remind them
of their stuffy aunts that used to spray
perfume everywhere
that smelled of sunflowers so for them
it may be a triggering smell whereas for
you it's a really relaxing smell
however there are some common
stress decreasing smells has been shown
by dr yoshinori
and these smells
include
lavender the aroma of coffee beans
cypress which is this really popular
tree in japan and lastly pine
so if you don't have any
emotional memories or negative emotional
memories with these smells you could
think of including them in your smell
environment
by for example
aromatherapy
or
perfume
so this was a little deep dive into the
research
on environmental factors that could
increase or decrease our stress response
and i hope when you think of redesigning
your environment you will think a little
bit about how to include some visual
factors such as nature to increase this
soft fascination and having a good light
source
some sound factors so playing some nice
piano music on the background
and lastly not to forget smell as well
so some fresh coffee grinds around or
some flowers it's always really nice and
then i think you will have this ultimate
perfect zen cave to produce all your
work
during these tough corona times
so thank you for joining me on coffee
time and hope to see you next time bye
[Music]
you